Fourteen years of Erdoganism has transformed
Turkey from ally to adversary. What
does this mean for the United States?
NATO is at risk.
The defensive alliance is run by
consensus, so single objection paralyzes
it. There is no mechanism to expel
wayward members. Even if Erdogan
doesn't seek NATO's destruction, Turkey
is an intelligence risk. Integrating
Russian S-400 missiles would mean
exposing NATO secrets to the Kremlin.
It gets worse: In fits of pique, Erdogan
exposed Israeli spies to Iran, and later
leaked the location of American forces
inside Syria to the Islamic State.
What comes next could be even worse: Hakan Fidan, Turkey's intelligence chief,
favors Tehran and Moscow over Washington.
Turkey is currently a partner on the
F-35 Joint Strike Fighter, America's
next-generation aircraft. Should the
Pentagon really trust Turkey not to
share the F-35 stealth technology with
Russia, Iran, and China? Don't even get me
started on Turkey's terror sponsorship.
What to do: It's time to stop pretending
Turkey is an ally. The best policies are
geared to reality, not the fantasy of how
things used to be.
Do you think the United States needs a new strategy toward Turkey? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.